في فرنسا خرجت مظاهرات ضد مشروع قانون
لاصلاح نظام التقاعد حيث اعلن حزب فرنسا
الابيه اليساري وعدد من المنظمات الشباب
تنظيم مسيرات احتجاجيه على اصلاح المثير
للجدل تعهد الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون
يوم الخميس الماضي
بالمضيق قدما فيه نتابعوا معكم هذه الصور
من باريس المظاهرات كما ذكرنا احتجاجا على
اصلاح نظام التقاعد الجديد
[تصفيق]
نعم يعني ااا هناك ااا محاوله لرفع السن
التقاعد وهؤلاء يحتجون منذ ايام على هذا
وهمم الرئيس ماكرون في الوقت ذاته كما قلت
هو يعد بالمضي قدما ولكن الاحتجاجات
مستمره سوف يخبرنا المزيد عن ذلك مراسل
الجزيره في باريس نور الدين بوزيان
المتواجد في هذه المظاهرات نور الدين هل
هناك استجابه
عثمان من السابق لاواني الحديث عن
الاستجابه لكن من المؤكده ان هذه المظاهره
لن تكون بحجم المظاهره التي خرجت يوم
الخميس نحن بسدد الحديث عن مظاهره وصل عدد
المشاركين فيها يومها كما تذكر الى حوالي
مليون ونصف متظاهر هذه الصور التي ننقلها
لكم مباشره هي لمظاهره دعت اليها الجمعيات
الطلابيه ولكن بعض احزاب اليسار انضمت
اليها يلاحظ في هذه المظاهره عثمان نفس
الشعارات التي تقول بان الشارع الفرنسي
يرفض
التقاعد وهمم اصلاح الحكومه النظام
التقاعد وترفض او يرفض هؤلاء همم ان يكون
ذلك على اساس ما تقترحه والحكومه ويقولون
بان هذه الاصلاحات في الحقيقه همم مضره
همم
المتقاعدين لاحقا وايضا لا تتوام مع كاسب
الاجتماعيات الفرنسيه طبعا من الشعارات
التي تم نقلها اليوم او رفعها همم هذا
التقاعد معناه كما يقولون هو من العمل
يذهب المتقاعد الى المقبره حسب ما يقولون
من الواضح ان ريهان القوه عثمان واضح في
هذه المظاهرات المستمره همم وهذه المظاهره
في الحقيقه هي للطلاب وكما قال احد
المستشارين للرئيس مكرونه انه عندما يخرج
الطلبه همم من السهل خروجهم لكن من الصعب
ان يعودوا الى بيوتهم في اشاره الى
الحركات الاحتجاجيه التي كانت الطلبه
نظامها في الماضي وكانت تتحول الى عمليه
عرقه للجامعات والثانويات يلاحظ ايضا ان
عدد من كبار السن موجودين هنا معنى ذلك ان
هناك مظاهره مشتركه بين الطلبه وايضا همم
من بقيه الفرنسيين ما يؤكد بان ربما بعض
الاحزاب الياسريه التي دعت الى تنظيم هذه
الم قد استجاب لها المنتسبون اليها لحد
هذه اللحظه لا احد يعرف هل ستنتهي هذه
المظاهره باعمال شغب على كل حال الشرطه
موجوده ولكن المخاوف قبل قليل تحدث الى
احد المسؤولين الامنيين قال اننا نخشى ان
تنتهي ربما باعمال شغب لاننا همم نعرف ان
لحد هذه اللحظه على حد ما قال يوجد على
الاقل او رصدنا على على همم بعض الجوانب
هذه المظاهره بعض المشاغبين على حد تعبيره
هذه هي اذا نقلنا لكم اجواء بدايه انطلاق
هذه المظاهره هنا في باريس عثمان
نعم
نعم اذا ونحن نشاهد يعني على كل حال حتى
الان نور الدين يبدو ان هنالك هدوء دعنا
نقل واعتقد ان الجميع يامل ان لا يتطور
الامر الى اي اعمال
شغب في كل الاحوال يعني حتى الامور حسب ما
نشاهد في الصور لا يبدو ان الامم المتجهه
في ذلك الاتجاه
نعم قلنا فقط ما قاله لنا مسؤول امني قبل
قليل الخوف علما بان السلطات الفرنسيه في
المظاهره السابقه التي جمعت اكثر من مليون
كانت كما تعلم جنه ما لا يقل عن همم
تقريبا ما يقل عن 1500 رجال الشرطه هنا في
فرنسا ومره الامور بسلام لكن هذه المره
هناك كثير من الشباب وهناك المخافه ان
يتحول همم غضب او تراكم الغضب في الشارع
الفرنسي ربما اقول ربما الى اعمال العنف
حتى هذه اللحظه نعم الامور تحت السيطره
لكن هناك بعض المجموعات التي تم رصدها
ربما ربما يقول ربما ستجرح الى همم رشق
قوات الامن كما كان يحدث في اكثر من
مظاهره على كل حال هذه المظاهره عثمان
تراهن عليها الحكومه
خاصه ان فرنسا مقبله على فتره انجازات ومع
ذلك الح لا تزال تراهن على شيئين اولا
انقسام النقابات اذكر بان النقابات
الثمانيه لاول مره منذ 12 عاما كانت يعني
توحدت في المظاهره يوم الخميس وايضا بعد
تلك المظاهره يوم الخميس التي جمعت اعداد
كبيره من الفرنسيين قررت مواصله الاضراب
والعوده الى حركه الاحتجاج يوم ال 31 من
هذا الشهر وحتى انا بعض النقابات قالت
بانها لن تكتفي فقط بالمظاهرات وانما تبدا
في عمليات تعطيل بعض القطاعات في اشاره
الى ربما شن حركه اضراب جديده خاصه في
قطاع النقل الحساس هنا في فرنسا عثمان
باريس شكرا جزيلا لك